all right you see them
all on the road and across the valley
and of course we're talking about the
food trucks now their goal of course to
make life easier and more convenient
yeah you got the taco trucks coffee
shaved ice you can find it all these
days sally jaramillo spoke to owners who
say business is picking up
with many people moving to southern
nevada they are also trying to start a
new business rolling out restaurants
while you may be seeing more of these
food trucks in your neighborhood yeah
throw them in there being able to
a phase one start with a food truck
before an actual restaurant this was a
great choice sean collins is co-owner
and chef of sean's puffy tacos he came
up with the idea shortly after the
pandemic started we did real well with
the pop-up and decided to buy a truck
and we're now on our 13th month
in the food truck and everything's gone
real well as the chef working for
himself and creating his own menu has
been a dream come true we're about 1 000
food trucks out there and they're all
great alicia cybersen co-owner and
marketing expert at sean's puppy taco
says there's definitely a culture when
it comes to the food truck industry the
sky's the limit at this moment the food
truck industry has become a tight-knit
industry and we really like working with
one another i definitely see them a lot
more aaron stewart owner of the secret
menu coffee says he started a year ago
right now it just makes the most sense
you can get stuck with property values
going up you can get stuck in a lease
and you can get a building and have to
pay enormous amounts of money whereas
you can relatively inexpensively you can
start a food truck food trucks they're
never going to go away and food truck
owners say thanks to younger generations
they will continue getting more momentum
sally jaramillo live local now